when I started copyrighting a couple
years ago I started very different than
most people okay so most people start
copyrighting by reading a couple
copywriting books right maybe taking a
course or two and then reaching out to
clients to write copy for them that is
their introduction to write and copy hey
I'll write some samples for you I kind
of figure this stuff out and blah blah
blah and they they start making some
connections well that's not how I
started copyrighting I started
copywriting by reading books studying
online and doing things like tweeting
online and building my email list and
writing emails for myself and creating
my own products and selling those own
products what I did was I made myself my
first client this is not typically
something I would recommend to people in
the past but now in 2025 and 2024 it is
absolutely something I'm recommending